I'm gonna have a question six some of
you I already know I past this if that's
the case i want you have a look at the
way I've set this out so you make sure
you do it in a civil way some of your
not so you're thinking in a little
confused myself I and walk you through
it now I keep on calling you back to
when did we first meet the idea of these
investing functions and the answer was
triangles at the right angle tralee and
you can find using these guys you could
find angles right and I kept on going to
that side investigatory fits examples 37
degrees when you have a look at this
therefore you can apply very similar
logic but i'll just give it to you with
a caution which is to remind you that
cos inverse sine inverse tan of us okay
you can think of them as angles and
triangles you can think of them as
angles and triangles but they are not
only anglers in triage okay a much
broader applications than that and
you've already seen some of them okay
but it is a very helpful way when you
think about this so have a look at this
one piece of time let's look at this
inside bit and see if we can understand
it cos inverse 03 fit if we think of it
as an angular triangle what kind of
triangle would it be now because we're
just thinking about a ratio it must be a
right angle triangle right so ever cared
I will draw a right angle triangle wow
that's a double right angle sorry yeah
it now cozy mess of three-fifths that
tells you that there's a ratio of two
sides here three and five right that's
the ratio it could be you know six and
ten or or you know i could multiply by
80 factor and i would still have the
same kind of triangle the ratios would
be the same right so that me it looks
like this would be the three and this
would be in five right where is this
angle if i call this angle theta where
is theta coz inverse of three-fifths
causes adjacent over hypotenuse izida
right so that's always the hypotenuse
but the angle for which this is the
adjacent side has a terrible sentence
the angle for which this is the inside
of this one right that's adjacent to the
three not this one down here okay so
therefore this angle really this is cos
inverse of three-fifths or it's equal to
that anyway okay so now if I want to
work out what side of that angle is sine
of theta okay all I need is the opposite
side and then it's just opposite on
hypotenuse right what's right angle to
the other side of course is for so it's
opposite on hypotenuse four-fifths okay
no problem I think you're quite master
that in fact eventually you will stop
drawing triangles and you think that's a
Pythagorean triad in there right you'll
start to work it out it's not that hard
but they throw a spanner in the works by
chucking negatives and have a look at a
question part 5 this is part 1 now I
know you can't see the screen so i'll
just write it out for you now how to
look at this with me what does is add
two things okay this negative right it
does make things more complicated it
breaks down this okay I can't use this
diagram any longer can anyone tell me
why it doesn't account for the fact that
something is going to be negative
because everything here is positive okay
so therefore what I'm going to do is I'm
going to draw myself with quarters
diagram I'm not a huge fan of quarters
diagrams but they can be a helpful tool
so you have a look at this okay by the
way all stations to central as you will
see shortly we will never have to worry
about this guy wonder if you can tell me
in fact me that's why okay now you start
again from the inside you go from inside
out you start from the surface thing and
then you add more stuff to it ok now
it's a tan inverse ratio right and it's
negative so out of these three quadrants
right which which projects are my
options well 10 verse what is the range
of tan inverse what's the range of tan
inverse we looked at this we graphed it
before it's from negative PI on to call
it fear to pile too right that's where
it's locked in which quadrant to those
which quadrants does this domain range
so does this range represent EDSA it
represents these two one and four
because this second quadrant these are
obtuse angles there are no obtuse angles
in this sub in this range right so these
are my options then I say okay it's
negative that restricts my options
further where is tan inverse going to be
negative is of this squadron on this one
and the answer is it must be this one
because they're all positive up here
right so I ditch this guy and what a
form a triangle Delphia and its ratio is
going to be for telling us that's
opposite on adjacent right opposite on
adjacent opposite is going to be length
1 and adjacent is going to be late three
okay now this will take some practice
okay I've done this millions in either
so either way to draw a straight away
that means my egg was going to look like
my train was going to look like that you
see why if I have my angle in here theta
okay the opposite side is the negative
one okay and the adjacent side is the
positive 3 okay can you see that see
what's going on now obviously if I went
over here town would still be negative
but it wouldn't be negative mind over 3
what would it be it'll be on 1 over
negative 3 because I'm a different
quadrant these are X's and Y's right but
i already know i'm in this quadrant okay
because of because of the domain the
range of ten emotion so now I've got my
feet are now I can see where theater is
so I can work out what caused theater is
I need a Jason
hypotenuse right I've got the adjacent
what is the hypotenuse in this case
square root of 10 isn't it yeah okay so
therefore this is adjacent adjacent on
hypotenuse that's three on route 10 and
the the textbook answers very awkwardly
rationalized that may give you that but
310 is fine okay so do you see what I
did there there's quite a few steps it
is let me walk through them again first
you start off with the question and you
want to say well look inside here
there's a tan inverse so that locks in
this range that tells you what the
possible quadrants are okay then you
look at what the actual value in there
is and that tells you which of the two
quadrants you actually are after once
you've got one you use these two to draw
in your actual triangle okay and be
careful which side is which you have to
think about arts opposite and adjacent
that's why my negative what am I three
are exactly where they are and then you
feel finally I need to take cause that's
the easy part isn't it okay the hard
part is in the construction of this and
making it accurate having the one in
three in the right spots and making sure
it's well cause is positive that's why
yeah okay that cost has to be positive
because a say doesn't actually matter